[Music]
Sky Terrace at Dawson was a prototype
HDB project that we undertook our idea
was to incorporate a few social issues
one was the idea of promoting
multi-generational living and the other
big idea that we had was how to have
housing in the park the
multi-generational design idea was to
design modular units that can stack idea
being that if three generations were to
apply to purchases flats you can have a
small elderly unit does interlock with
the l-shaped sectional normal unit for a
couple that both ones and they have to
look after a young child and elderly
you'll be very easy to live together but
still provide some privacy and dignity
to the elderly
in other words the outlay has a key to
go into the studio unit while the
children and the family live below
these two units have started unified
through a series of interlocking concern
and we even integrated the children's
playground with the outlet exercise
station idea that we don't separate the
generations having the policy of trying
to to create a solution of housing
generations together in the aging
society like ours a solution has been
found and I think in this particular
project we addressed issue of caregiving
by integrating the dwellings next to
each other and by stacking them together
it means that we also reduced on travel
and a much more sustainable solution
[Music]